square enix has had a big year in 2016
but it looks like 2017 isn't going to be
a slouch either near autumn mata is
coming out sometime in 2017 in the US
and Mike McCartney here has spent some
time playing the game so for people that
haven't played it all or don't know what
this is it is kind of an obscure
franchise what is near Audubon so I only
played a few hours of the original near
which released in 2010 and it's just
this over-the-top pretty you know like
action-oriented JRPG but now the thing
that's exciting me with a near auto
motto is that platinum games of vanquish
Bayonetta and metal gear rising
revengeance fame is working on the
actual action elements of auto matta so
there is like action-heavy sequences
like it's very much like feels like a
kind of devil may cry third-person
combat there's like bullet hell
sequences you get like these crazy
attacks but yeah the story itself is
super weird so apparently it's set like
millennia after the first game though so
you don't really need to play the first
one if you're like me and only played a
couple hours I went into this demo and I
came out really excited yeah it's coming
off of the drakengard series which the
first year was a spin-off oven and this
one's a little bit further along did you
get any of the the craziness of the plot
Bell like the story can take some really
weird turns as we saw with the first
year yeah a little bit so you play as to
be I believe her name is she's like an
Android kind of drone sent down or
cyborg known i have a cyborg clean
android sent down from the moon where
humans have escaped to because robots
have taken over the earth so when you
come back it's very much like iron
rusted kind of uh you know like at least
a level I've played on was um you know
like this rusted factory level although
in the distance and according to the
developers who i was playing next to on
a couch they said that it's an open
world just combine kind of with that
platinum games action which is super
exciting combination but yeah you come
back down to earth to pretty much clear
it of the robots to you know start
paving the way for humans to come back
and you eventually get these other
allies i forget there's like nine d i
forget all the cyborgs names i probably
won't sink in until i play more the game
but yeah definitely kind of an
outrageous story but you know just
setting the scene for the action that
kind of unfolds so when you say that it
has platinum games action does it does
it feel like it takes a lot of that
stylistic combat of something like
Bayonetta does it or does it feel kind
of fresh and different it feels
different enough in the pods that's kind
of the defining factor here these are
these little like robot drones that kind
of help you out and you know augment
your moves in certain ways whether it's
just blades spinning around you or just
this like spike ball of Spears that
shoots outward and you keep ranking them
out up throughout the game you can also
use the pods to kind of like shoot like
we do range attacks um but in terms of
the fluidity and the you know the kind
of seamless flow from one attack to the
next between light attacks heavy attacks
range attacks the jumping the air
juggling definitely feels like a
platinum games action game but enough so
but enough of its different that it
actually kind of like is drawing me in
like before I play more but as a square
enix game and as coming from near and
drakengard it does have some RPG
elements as well right yeah I mean
between our ranking up your pods I
believe you'll you know you gather this
currency that you kind of used to rank
your carrots are about being to be
throughout the game yeah you are you're
exploring the world they're gonna I
don't know what this the quest structure
will be like the head and said much
about that so in terms of like
overarching RPG mechanics I think just
mainly the character progression it's
what's going to be driving you as far as
like how the open world will function I
got to a boss fight and then they stop
me right before it at the end of the
factory level which is a shame because
the rest of levels really fun and really
well designed but I didn't get to see
the how the open world would function
one thing I did really like is the
camera in this game just like any of you
know action games third person actually
made her like made or broken by their
camera and the Platinum Games has
demonstrated time and again that they're
really good with this the camera would
sometimes zoom out and then a lot of
these like r2d2 like George would be
shootin like these large orbs at me and
then I would you know be jumping or
dodging them like a bullet hell game
while responding with my own range
attacks or if you dodge the right time
you can counter-attack just like other
like platinum games but overall it felt
very fluid and then it was very
responsive in terms of the combat I'm
really excited to see how the open world
will draw me in and explore because in
the distance you can see like forests
mountains other cities kind of overgrown
more like the last of us kind of
overgrown as opposed to like the rusted
factory I had played in yeah but as far
as the overarching RPG mechanics they
haven't told me too much yet and near is
more of a cult series i think it's
interesting that they're going with
autumn oughtta instead of calling it
like near to so it can maybe feel as a
new game that you're getting into that
said having that weirdness having kind
of a history of a very different kind of
game that what's typically popular here
in the West you do you feel like this
one might be the kind that could catch
on do you feel like it has potential
yeah despite the weird name which like
metal gear rising revengeance also kind
of had to say the least I think it will
catch on i think that platinum games
influence will bring more people in
because i know a lot of complaints
myself included even though the few
hours i played a venir weren't a lot
where that the action itself felt kind
of janky it didn't feel like it was
feeding into the overall game as much
now it feels like the open world I'm
hoping will draw me a more but the
moment-to-moment action is like just so
engrossing that I don't even care
whether the open world works that well I
was just so fun to jump do like a
downward kind of spiral attack activate
a pod that spun swords around me if I
you know fire range attack and another
range droid and then just like
counter-attack this giant robot fighting
me I'm looking forward to the boss
fights they say the demo will be
available sometime in the coming months
they did not give me like a window or a
release date I am looking forward to
playing that so i can fight that boss
that they stop me from fighting but yeah
i think this could catch on the west
when it releases in 2017 alright so so
it sounds like near auto mata could be a
really interesting title it's going to
be coming out early in Japan we don't
have a firm release date but sometime in
2017 in worldwide in the US and if you
want to read more about it or see the
game in action be sure to stay tuned to
gamespot com
you